Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. In former times, Greece was considered the first country in the world where the fair sex had acquired a superior taste in their vestments,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告音频以及加入我们的聊天社群，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是 Apple Podcasts App，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。过去，希腊被认为是世界上第一个让女性在服饰上展现出卓越品味的国度，
and every person of taste has admired the elegant simplicity of their dresses. In our memory, France has given her dresses to other nations, but it was reserved for the graces of Great Britain to take the lead in fashion and to show that if they do not surpass, they certainly equal the elegance of the most celebrated Grecian dresses. In short, beauty, shape and taste are nowhere more general nor anywhere better united than in England. So, Tom Holland, those were the words of Nikolaus von Heidloff, the Bruno of the 18th century, top fashion writer. A German engraver from Stuttgart who worked in paris then went to london and did a a gallery of fashion in the 1790s and early 1800s and um i mean that's pretty much the case now isn't it tom i mean in all seriousness you'll very rarely meet a foreigner who's who's better
每个有品味的人都曾赞叹过其服饰优雅的简洁性。在我们的记忆中，法国曾将自己的服装引领给其他国家，但引领时尚并展现出英国女性的优雅即使不超越、也绝对能媲美最著名的希腊服饰的桂冠，则属于大不列颠的美人们。简而言之，无论在哪个地方，英国的美丽、身段和品味都更为普遍，也融合得更好。那么，汤姆·霍兰，这些话是18世纪的“布鲁诺”、顶级时尚作家尼古劳斯·冯·海德洛夫所写。他是一位来自斯图加特的德国雕刻家，曾在巴黎工作，后来前往伦敦，并在18世纪90年代和19世纪初创作了时尚画廊……呃，我的意思是，现在情况差不多也是这样，对吧，汤姆？说真的，你很难遇到一个衣着比英国人更好的外国人。
dressed than an englishman that's true i think that's right and i think our beauty shape and taste remain the envy of the world absolutely trampled yeah the envy of the world. And Dominic, I mean, I like to think that we're a patriotic podcast, aren't we? Very much. And it strikes me listening to that that we don't begin our episodes with enough patriotic reflections on how great... And I know that we have a lot of overseas listeners from the
那是真的，我想确实如此，而且我认为我们的美丽、身段和品味依然令世界艳羡。绝对没错，是的，令世界艳羡。多米尼克，我的意思是，我倾向于认为我们是一个爱国播客，对吧？非常是。听了刚才那番话，我突然觉得我们的节目在开始时，缺乏足够的爱国主义反思，来赞美……而且我知道我们有很多来自美国、澳大利亚等海外的听众，我想他们可能会同意我们的看法。我确信他们会同意我们的看法。他们绝不会反对我们到目前为止所说的任何内容……所以，多米尼克，冯·海德洛夫所指的这个时期，是摄政时期，对吧？是的，而且我认为摄政时期以其服饰而闻名，对吧？呃，无论是柯林·费斯从南部的湖泊中湿身走出，还是像你们知道的《布里奇顿》里那种充满泡沫和幻想的摄政风貌，都非常非常独特，而且你知道的，它……
United States, Australia and so on, and I think they'll probably agree with us. I'm sure they'll agree with us. They won't in any way be disagreeing with anything we've said so far so so this is so dominic this the the period that that um that von heidloff is referring to is it's the regency period yeah and i would say the regency period is i mean it's famed for its dress isn't it uh so whether it's colin firth emerging from a lake in a southern lake or like you know so or bridgerton with all the kind of the froth and the fantasy of that the regency look is something really really distinctive um and you know it's it's it's
它一直以来都……呃，很有趣，人们在阅读简·奥斯汀的作品时，就会意识到她所描绘的世界表面上的宁静其实是虚幻的。因为在背景中，有工业革命，有革命战争，有拿破仑战争，还有英国作为全球化角色的影响——有好的方面，也绝对有坏的方面。这就是为什么我……当我偶然读到一本由时尚历史学家兼策展人希拉里·戴维森（Hilary Davidson）撰写的名为《简·奥斯汀时代的服饰》（Dress in the Age of Jane Austen）的书时，我真的、真的非常着迷。这是一本非常棒的书，因为它基本上……
it's always been kind of uh interesting people have been aware when they look at Jane Austen that the seeming kind of tranquility of the world that she's portraying is illusory. Because in the background, you have the Industrial Revolution, you have revolutionary wars, Napoleonic wars, you have Britain's globalizing role for good and definitely for bad as well. And that was why I was, I was really, really fascinated to come across a book by Hilary Davidson, who is a fashion historian and curator called dress in the age of Jane Austin. And it is, it's a fantastic book because basically it,
它回答了时尚界到底发生了什么的问题。而且其中确实有一些非常、非常独特和别具一格的东西。这不仅仅是关于外表，更是关于变革的速度和进程，我认为这使它真正具有革命性。我很高兴地宣布，希拉里本人今天也来到了我们节目中。你好，希拉里。你好。希拉里，你是澳大利亚人，对吧？是的，我是。那你对多米尼克的爱国主义作何感想？显然，我无法反驳他说的任何话。这都是真的。
it answers the question of what is going on in the world of fashion. And there is something really, really distinctive and unique. It's not just about the look. It's about the pace and the process of change that marks it out, I think, as properly revolutionary. And I'm delighted to say that we actually have Hilary with us. Hello, Hilary. Hello. And Hilary, you're Australian, aren't you? I am, yes. So how do you feel about Dominic's patriotism? Obviously, I can't disagree with anything he says. It's all true.
我想我们大概就应该在这里结束播客了，汤姆。那么，希拉里，在你的书中，你基本上是在说，摄政时期的女帽、高腰长裙、达西先生的衬衫以及所有这些东西，都是一个革命时代的表达，而且这是某种激进的新事物。那么，在哪些方面呢？就像在摄政时期——我认为大约始于1790年代中期——人们开始彻底改变他们之前对服装的所有看法。这是一个非常棒的过渡时期，把我们带入了现代。这一时期的许多服装元素，正如你所说，这种非常独特的服装，
I think we should probably end the podcast right there, Tom. So Hilary, in your book, basically, you were saying that the Regency period, the bonnets, the Empire Line dresses, the Mr. Darcy shirt and all that kind of stuff, that these are the expressions of a revolutionary age and that this is something radically new. So in what way? It's like during the Regency period, which I think of as sort of starting about the mid 1790s, it's like people start transforming all the ways they've thought about clothing before. And it's just a fantastic kind of middle period that gets us from into the modern age. And so many of the elements of dress of this period, this very distinctive dress, as you say,
它们在前几年就开始酝酿，然后催化了。比如女性服装的轮廓完全从三角形和宽大的版型转变为这种圆柱形。而男装则采用了我们今天仍然熟悉的类似三件套西装的轮廓。这种服装变革的速度是我们从未见过的，但它完全植根于社会、文化、工业和政治的变革之中。总的来说，如果你身处18世纪中期——也就是我们今天要谈论的摄政时期之前的时代，你穿的东西会是一样的吗？比如说在1770年或1780年？你的穿着打扮大致和你的父辈差不多吗？服装的基本原则、
they're building in the years before, but then it catalyzes. And it's things like the silhouette of women's dress just changes completely from kind of triangles and breadth into this column shape. And men's dress takes on the silhouettes that we're still familiar with from kind of a three-piece suit today. And it's clothing transformation at a speed that we've never seen before, but it's all rooted in social, cultural, industrial and political change. So by and large, if you're in the mid 18th century, so the age before what we're going to be talking about today, the Regency period, are you wearing the same things, let's say in 1770 or 1780? Are you roughly dressed like your parents were before you roughly the principles of
如何搭配以及基本版型都非常相似……呃，当然时尚也在不断变化，细节上涉及体积和轮廓，但模板是一样的，对吧？是的，所以一个男子穿着长筒袜、马裤……还有马裤，对吧，完全是的，还有某种衬衫、某种外套、一件背心，外面再套一件外套。不过这件外套并不强调肩膀，大部分臃肿的体积都在臀部和大腿周围，还要扑粉或者戴假发，当时还要穿高跟鞋。这时候，我们应该从阶级而非性别的角度来谈论。我们还应该指出，基本上在本期节目中，我们谈论的是那些有足够资金投资时尚的人，这 vermutlich 只是少数人。
clothing and how you put it together and the sort of the the basic shapes are very similar uh you know with fashions changing at pace there's details about volume and silhouette but the the template is the same yes right so a bloke is wearing stockings um and britches and britches yeah exactly yeah and a sort of and a sort of a shirt i guess and a and a and a coat and a waistcoat and then a coat on top of that but the coat doesn't have an emphasis on the shoulders and a lot of the bulk is kind of around the hips and thighs and powdered hair or wig and high heels and high heels at this point. So we should say about class rather than about gender. And we should also say that essentially in this episode, we're talking about people with enough money to invest in
中产绅士专业阶层及以上的人，在当时大约占英国人口的20%到25%。没错。引人注目的是，正是到了1790年代，一切才真正开始发生改变。这在多大程度上受到了法国大革命的影响？法国大革命当然也是在那个时期爆发的。嗯，我认为这是个重大问题，在时尚史上也得到了很多讨论。但在我看来，革命本身被赋予了太多作为变革推动者的角色，而它更像是一个正在发生的变革的标志。我觉得法国大革命那些震撼欧洲大陆的事件，其实是正在发生的更广泛革命的一部分。而服饰——服装所发生的变化，其标志尤为明显，那就是女性的腰线上移了，
fashion, which is presumably quite a minority. The sort of the middling gentry professional classes and above, which at this point is about 20, 25% of Britain's population. Right. So it's striking that it's the 1790s where everything really starts to change. To what extent is that influenced by the French Revolution, which of course is also kicking in at that time? Well, I think this is one of the great questions and it's discussed a lot in fashion history, but to my way of thinking, the revolution itself is assigned a lot of driver for the change rather than being a kind of a marker of the change that's happening. I feel like the continent shaking events of the French Revolution, they're part of wider revolutions that are going on. And dress, what happens to dress, where particularly the marker is that women's waistlines go up,
它们在大约三到四年的时间里，从自然的腰线直接移到了胸部下方，这速度快得惊人。而且这种趋势无论如何都在酝酿中。因此，那时的服装参与了许多革命，而它恰好与革命时期所促进或大声疾呼的许多民主理想不谋而合。那么，我的意思是——我们可以稍后讨论其他革命，比如工业革命，或者更广泛的启蒙运动——但就顺着这一点问，为什么高腰线更具民主性呢？
they move from the natural waistline to right under the bust in about a three to four year period, which is incredibly fast. And that was building anyway. And so clothing at this time is partaking of many revolutions. And it just happens to kind of fit neatly with many of the democratic ideals that are being uh you know promoted or made more vocal by the revolutionary period so how is i mean we can go into things other revolutions like the industrial revolution or indeed the enlightenment more generally in a second but just to pick up on that why is a higher
嗯，这不仅是高腰线的问题，而是整件长裙的结构方式。因此，服饰的一大革命是从丝绸制度向棉布制度的转变。平纹细布成了一种可接受的、时髦的纺织品——也就是那种白色、轻薄、半透明的面料。这种趋势自1780年代后期以来一直在酝酿，当时玛丽·安托瓦内特穿着一件非常简单的平纹细布制成的长裙出现在肖像画中，震惊了法国宫廷，这种长裙当时被视为像内衣或某种女性贴身内衣。但到了1790年代，这种轻盈、简单的服装环绕着身体垂下，不再需要内部结构来支撑出形状，
waistline more democratic well it's it's not just the higher waistline, it's the whole way gowns are constructed. So one of the big revolutions in dress is a shift from a silk regime to a cotton regime. And muslin becomes an acceptable, the white kind of thin translucent fabric, it becomes an acceptable fashionable textile. And this has been building since the late 1780s when Marie Antoinette scandalized the French court by appearing in a portrait dressed in a very simple dress made of muslin that was seen to be like a chemise or kind of women's underwear. But by the 1790s, this kind of light, simple clothing that draped around the body instead of requiring
它被视为对古代世界、古典希腊和罗马的回溯，让女性看起来像雕塑一样，并成为将生命与艺术相连的世界哲学基础的新理想的一部分。这里面酝酿着很多这样的理念。所以，回过头来说，我们讨论了18世纪中期男性的着装。那么在18世纪中期，中产阶级及以上的女性，她们的着装并不是那种古典风格的。
structures underneath to give it shape, it was seen to hark back to the ancient world, to classical Greece and Rome, and to make women look like statues and to be part of new ideals of thinking about philosophical underpinnings of the world to be connecting life and art. That's kind of a lot of the ideas that are brewing in that. So to go back a second, we talked about how men dressed in the mid-18th century. So a woman, a woman of the sort of middling sort upwards in the mid-18th century is not dressed in that sort of classical way.
她们的着装非常、非常精致、僵硬，带有所有的……我其实不太明白束腹撑（stays）是什么。什么是束腹撑？我很高兴你提到这个，因为这真的很重要。束腹撑的变化同样是向摄政时期服装转变的关键标志之一。所以，束腹撑就是有时被称为紧身胸衣（corsets）的东西，但在18世纪还不是。它们是一种女性穿着的、经过加固以提供支撑的躯干服饰。
She's dressed in very, very elaborate, sort of rigid, with all – I don't really understand what stays are. What are stays? I'm glad you brought that up because it's really important. The changes in stays is, again, one of the key markers of the change into Regency dress. So stays are what are sometimes called corsets, but they weren't in the 18th century. And they are a stiffened supportive torso garment that women wear.
所以，它大致从胸部一直延伸到腰部，通常前面带有某种尖角，它为胸部提供支撑，并为外衣塑形。所以它有点像一个倒三角形。这就是他们追求的形状。而在它的底部是一条裙子，根据你所处的时代和你在做的事情，其蓬松度和宽度会有所不同。但这一切都围绕着这种非常柔软、僵硬且不自然的身体形状。如果你原谅我冒昧地问一句，为什么束腹撑不是紧身胸衣？因为它们在摄政时期变成了紧身胸衣。好的。
So, it runs kind of from the bust down to the waist, generally with a sort of pointed front, and it provides support for the bosom, and it gives shape to the outer garment. So, it's kind of like an inverted triangle. That's the shape they're going for. And then on the bottom of that is a skirt of varying sort of degrees of volume and width according to where you are in time and what you're doing. But it's all around this kind of very soft, rigid, unnatural body shape. So if you'll forgive me, why are the stays not a corset? Because they become a corset in the Regency period. Okay.
是的。但它们不是紧身胸衣。因为你刚才描述的听起来非常像紧身胸衣，不过这是我个人的看法。我对18世纪女性内衣的了解没有应有的那么多。不，听着，这是一个非常、非常普遍的误解。问题在于，因为我们经历了19世纪伟大的紧身胸衣时代——也就是人们一想到紧身胸衣就会想到的那种塑造腰部、沙漏型身材的东西，汤姆一直在想紧身胸衣……米勒莉在那里保持安静，汤姆，我无可奉告。
Yeah. But they're not a corset. Because what you described sounds very much like a corset to me, but this is me. I'm not familiar with women's, 18th century women's underwear as much as I should be. No, look, this is a really, really common mistake. The thing is that because we have lived through the great 19th century period of corsets, which is what people think of when they think of corsets the kind of the waist shaping the hourglass figure we tom thinks about corsets all the time millery remaining very quiet there tom i i have no comment
但我只想向你引述一个叫威廉·巴克姆（William Buckham）的人的话，他在1811年说：“一想到过去由鲸须制成的硬直紧身背心和紧身系带，确实让人感到震惊和某种程度的恐惧。”据推测，他当时可能既在谈论女性，也在谈论男性，因为你提到摄政王和他的兄弟坎伯兰公爵是如此肥胖，以至于他们也不得不穿束腹撑来压缩胃部……但就坚持探讨……这种类似束腹撑的衰落与法国大革命同时发生的这种现象，有一种感觉，对吧——通过抛弃紧身胸衣，你在法国肯定是在拥抱一种政治自由主义，一种政治自由。我的意思是，这样说会不会太夸张了？如果并不夸张，那为什么它在英国也同时发生呢？因为按理说英国是在把自己定位为与革命的法国对立，反对这些传统服饰的放松。法国和英国时尚之间的关系，
but what i would just to introduce you you quote a guy called william buckham who in 1811 is saying it is indeed impossible to think of the old straight waistcoat of whalebone and of tight lacing without astonishment and some degree of horror. And presumably he might be talking about men as well as women then, because you say about how the Prince Regent and his brother, the Duke of Cumberland, are so fat that they have to wear stays as well to compress their stomachs but just just sticking on on the the way in which um this kind of the the the decline of the stays as it were coincides with the french revolution there is there is a sense isn't there that by casting off corsetry you are embracing in france certainly you're embracing a kind of political liberalism, a kind of political freedom. I mean, would that be too excessive to say that? And if it is, then why is it happening in Britain as well? Because presumably Britain is defining itself against revolutionary France, against these kind of relaxations of traditional dress. The relationship between sort of French and
以及谁影响谁，是复杂且多层次的。而且你当然在法国，在概念上抛弃了以前的枷锁——我的意思是，正如我所说，这在整个1780年代的艺术和宫廷圈子里一直在酝酿——所以法国大革命某种程度上将其体现结晶化了。但在英国也是如此，我认为有一种自由和民主的感觉，因为对法国的许多人来说，没有绝对君主的英国议会模式——而这正是法国大革命所要废除的——一直具有影响力，我们在男装中也能看到这一点。
British fashion and who influences whom is is difficult and multi-layered and you're certainly in france kind of conceptually that casting off of previous shackles i mean as i say this has been building in art and court circles throughout the 1780s um so the french revolution kind of um crystallizes this manifestation. But in Britain as well, I think there's that sense of liberty and democracy because for many in France, the British parliamentary model where you do not have an absolute monarch, which is, of course, what the French Revolution is disposing of, has often been influential, which we see in menswear when we talk about that.
所以，我的意思是，这里面也有时尚的一般浪潮。随着事情的发生，人们接受了它们。但还有一种新的自然主义，据说也极其符合英国人的性格，即英国人是随性、自然、简单、不做作的，不像法国人那样大惊小怪、小题大做。所以这里面带有一点浪漫主义色彩，对吧？也就是从理性、有序转向更加自由……我是不是有点过度解读了，还是说……不，我认为这是一个非常合理的观点。尽管在服装中采纳古典影响据说是为了审视那种干净、纯粹、哲学的古代世界，但这绝对是一种浪漫主义。
So there is, I mean, there are also sort of the general tides of fashion. As things happen, people embrace them. But there's a new naturalism that is also supposedly very commensurate with the British character, that the British are easy, they are natural, they are simple, they're not affected and fussy like the French, obviously. So there's a slight element of romanticism in that, isn't't there that there's sort of a turn away from the sort of the the rational and the ordered to a freer is that am i am i over egging that or is that no i
而且1790年代也是欧洲大陆哲学中浪漫主义哲学正在形成的时期。所以它是对过去的回顾，并以此作为对时尚中略带戏服感的事物的影响。一个标志性的例子就是爱玛·汉密尔顿（Emma Hamilton），对吗？是的。那么给我们讲讲爱玛·汉密尔顿吧，她嫁给了英国驻那不勒斯大使，但最著名的是与纳尔逊海军上将保持着恋爱关系，她可以说是一个名人，对吧？因为她身着飘逸的古典长裙摆姿势而闻名，而且在某种意义上，她是一个非常、非常浪漫的人物。她绝对是。而且当时有地位、有人脉的人去那不勒斯时，做的一件事就是去看爱玛·汉密尔顿的“姿势”（attitudes）。她会摆出这些静态造型，基本上只用布料和围巾。
think that's a very valid point and for all that the adoption of kind of classical influence in dress is supposedly you know looking into that kind of clean, pure, philosophical ancient world. It is absolutely a romanticism. And the 1790s is also the period where in continental philosophy, the romantic philosophers is building. So it's looking back at the past and kind of, you know, using it as an influence for what's slightly costumey in fashion. So an emblematic example of that would be Emma Hamilton, would it? Yes. So tell us about Emma Hamilton, who marries the British ambassador to Naples, but is most famous for
同样，本着那种非常简单的传统，她会摆出姿势，形成受古典世界启发并深受其丈夫收集的古董文物影响的静物画。那些看过的人很难准确描述其特殊品质，但它似乎……几乎带有魔力。她似乎能从过去中走出来。而且她这样做时，她那一头华丽的栗色长发散落至膝盖，（你知道的）仅仅包裹在非常简单的服装中。有大量证据表明，她的名气、美貌和受欢迎程度对当时从英国返程的旅行者也产生了很大影响，比如查洛特·坎贝尔夫人（Lady Charlotte Campbell），她后来开始模仿的与其说是古典服装，不如说是爱玛·汉密尔顿版本的古典服装。这就引发了一个关于更广泛时尚的有趣问题，那就是，
having a relationship with Admiral Nelson, but who is kind of a celebrity, isn't she, for her kind of attitudinizing in wispy classical dress, but is a very, very romantic figure in every sense of the word. She absolutely is. And one of the things that, you know, people of good standing and connections did when they went to Naples was to go and see Emma Hamilton's attitudes. And she would kind of do these tableaus where just using basically drapery and scarves. And again, in that very simple tradition, she would kind of take attitudes and form like still lives that were inspired by the classical world and much by the sort of antiquarian objects that her husband collected. And there was people who saw it kind
这是一个时尚——时尚的概念——存在的时代。“时尚”这个词？非常流行。这在多大程度上取决于个人潮流引领者？所以，（你知道的）爱玛·汉密尔顿就是个经典的例子，我想，或者玛丽·安托瓦内特。其次，它是如何传播的？所以它完全是通过印刷文化吗？是通过小册子，嗯，我猜还有报纸？我的意思是，它是如何……它是如何传播的？对我来说，这是在真正研究摄政时期并试图确定时尚是如何传播的过程中最有趣的事情之一。就我所能了解到的而言，它确实是通过人来传播的。视觉印刷媒体的影响远没有我们想象的那么大。
of had trouble describing the particular quality of it, but it seemed to sort of, it was magical almost. She seemed to kind of step out of the past. And she was doing so with all of her magnificent chestnut hair unbound to her knees, you know, just wrapped in very simple clothing. And there's a lot of evidence to suggest that her fame and beauty and popularity was also very influential on travellers then returning home from Britain, people like Lady Charlotte Campbell, who then started kind of imitating not so much classical dress, but Emma Hamilton's version of classical dress. So that raises the interesting question about fashion more generally, which is,
我们留下了成千上万的摄政时期时尚版画，但那并不是人们真正受其影响的方式。我们还必须记住，当时的英国社会要小得多。所以如果你在伦敦，你很有可能在街上或海德公园看到查洛特·坎贝尔夫人。你实际上可以去观察伦敦的时尚制造者、潮流引领者。然后，如果你去你的女帽店、裁缝店，他们会告诉你其他人都在买什么。即使你住在更远的乡下，你在伦敦的表妹、朋友也会说：“我看到某某夫人穿了这样那样的衣服，”或者“我注意到这种面料或这种款式正在流行，”简·奥斯汀在她的书信中经常这样做。
this is an age where fashion, the idea of fashion exists. The word fashion? Very much so. And how much does that depend on, first of all, how much does that depend on individual trendsetters? So, you know, Emma Hamilton is the classic example, I suppose, or Marie Antoinette. And secondly, how is that disseminated? So is it all through print culture? Is it through pamphlets and, well, I guess, newspapers? I mean, how does it, how does it, yeah, how does it travel? For me, this has been one of the most interesting things in really researching the Regency period
所以有一种通过他们自己的经历进行传递的感觉。然后人们也会观察其他人的穿着并加以吸收。我认为这实际上仍然这一时期最强大的时尚传播渠道。但按理说，为了让这种模式起作用，你需要一定程度的基础设施，让人们能够看到一位时髦女性及其穿着，然后进行效仿。所以你需要商店、女帽店、面料，你需要能够做到这一点的工业基础设施。而正是在这个时代，拿破仑才有了那句著名的嘲讽，称英国人为“小店主的民族”。你认为拥有这种基础设施，在加速这种时尚产业的创造方面发挥了多么重要的作用？它绝对是巨大的。你知道的，
and trying to determine how fashion does travel. And as far as I can tell, it's really through people. The influence of visual print media is not nearly as strong as we think it is at the time. We are left with thousands of Regency fashion plates, but that's kind of not how people were really getting their influence. We also have to remember that British society is much smaller at the time. So if you're in London, it's very likely you could see Lady Charlotte Campbell on the street or in Hyde Park. You can actually go and watch the fashion makers, the tastemakers in London. And then if you're
在18世纪末期的这个时期，沿着斯特兰德大街（the Strand）或牛津街（Oxford Street），基本上有四英里的商店。然后，（你知道的）更深入到梅菲尔（Mayfair）和邦德街（Bond Street）等更时尚的地区。所以，伦敦到处都是零售商、批发商和仓库，人们不仅去伦敦购物——就像《傲慢与偏见》中班内特太太因为莉迪亚不知道伦敦最好的仓库在哪里而惊慌失措那样。首都以外的较小零售商也从伦敦进货。他们会去城里，然后把库存带回来，同时看看人们在那里穿什么、做什么。因此，存在一个强大的传播网络。你也可以通过邮寄来购买。人们会给你寄面料样品。
going to your milliner, your dressmaker, they're going to tell you what other people are buying. And even if you're further out into the country, your cousin, your friend who's in London can say, I saw a lady so-and-so wearing such and such, or, you know, I noticed that these veils or this kind of thing is in fashion, which Jane Austen does a lot in her letters. So there's a sense of kind of people transmitting through their own experience. And then also people watching what other people are wearing and taking that on board. And I think that that's actually still the strongest transmitter of fashion in this period. But presumably for that to work, you need a certain
有很多代购，如果你的朋友要去主要城市中心——可能是伦敦或巴斯，甚至曼彻斯特、伯明翰、爱丁堡——他们会代你购物。你会说：“请帮我买最时髦的平纹细布，”或者“我想要一件非常漂亮的黄色印花细布（cane brick）。”然后他们会去看看别人穿什么，收集情报，回来后说：“这是看起来不错的，”或者“这是我能买到的，”或者“他们说这是最合适的。”所以它确实依赖于人际网络和社会基础设施，正是这些支撑着中产阶级及以上阶层，而且（你知道的）奥斯汀的小说在某种程度上确实展示了这些联系和人际关系是如何运作的。而时尚也完全沿着这些路线发展。
degree of infrastructure for people to see a fashionable woman, what she's wearing, and then to have it copied. So you'd need the shops, you'd need the milliners, you'd need the fabrics, you'd need the industrial infrastructure that would be capable of doing it. And this is the age when Napoleon famously dismisses the British as a nation of shopkeepers. Is the fact that you have this infrastructure, is that, do you think, how important a role is that playing in kind of expediting this creation of a fashion industry? It's absolutely huge. You know, at this sort of period in the late 18th century, along the strand that are along Oxford Street, it's basically four miles of shops. And then, you know, further into sort of the more fashionable areas in Mayfair and along
那么，除了你认为最时髦的大都市之外，传播的速度有多快呢？换句话说，如果你想想一个不同的时代——比如人们对20世纪60年代常开玩笑说，卡纳比街（Carnaby Street）上的每个人都穿着迷你裙，但在赫尔（Hull），直到2012年人们才开始穿迷你裙。赫尔的人们多久才会穿上受这个世界的“爱玛·汉密尔顿们”启发的最新时尚？基本上只要信息和收入允许，他们就会穿。所以，如果你有经济条件，并且热切期待伦敦关于最新时尚的消息，然后你走进当地的商店说：“好吧，我要买一块平纹细布，试着模仿这个，”你就可以相当快地做到这一点。
Bond Street. So, London is absolutely full of retailers and wholesalers and warehouses and not only are people going to London to shop, as in Pride and Prejudice when Mrs. Bennett is panicking because Lydia won't know the best warehouses to go to in London. Smaller retailers outside the capital are also buying from London. They will go up to town and then bring their stock in and also see what people are wearing and doing there. So there is a robust network of transmission. And you could also do it by mail. So people would send you fabric samples. There was a lot of proxy shopping where if a friend of yours is going to a major urban center, it could be London or Bath, but even Manchester, Birmingham, Edinburgh,
有一种观点认为，因为——我喜欢摄政时期的另一个原因，是澳大利亚有一段历史，当时已经有了白人殖民的历史。但是澳大利亚的英国定居者需要等待六个月才能从英国收到货物，其实这并不比你住在威尔士山区或苏格兰高地长多少。所以它的速度可以相对较快。事实上，爱尔兰作家玛丽亚·埃奇沃思（Maria Edgeworth）有一句精彩的名言，她说：“凭借我们现在拥有的邮政和道路，几乎每个人都可以同时知道其他人在做什么，”这就像神奇的仙女一样——你知道的，在我们这个时代看来这似乎非常慢。但她对人们能如此迅速地得知正在发生的事情以及什么是时尚感到印象深刻。
they will go and shop on your behalf. And you say, please get me the most fashionable muslin, or I want a very nice yellow cane brick. And then they will go and see what other people are wearing and kind of get the intelligence and come back and go, this is what looked nice, or this is what I could get, or this is what they say is the most appropriate. So it really is relying on networks of acquaintance and that social infrastructure that so holds up the middle classes and above and that, you know, Austen's novels in a sense really demonstrate how those connections and acquaintance work. And fashion is running exactly along those lines as well. And then what's the speed of transmission beyond what you would consider the most fashionable
但多米尼克，多米尼克将这与60年代进行了比较——在60年代，那种强烈的代沟感，以及时尚弄潮儿通过用更为老派的着装观念去震惊他人来获得快乐的心理非常强烈——我真的印象深刻，你引述了一本杂志的描写，它描述了“震惊的老太太”和“嗤之以鼻的老先生”悲叹现代的倾向、对传统的完全缺乏尊重、当今女孩行为的大胆，特别是她服装的极端不得体。我的意思是，这简直可以用来描述……这简直可以用来描述60年代，对吧？我的意思是，真的非常深刻。所以，所有这些时尚革命，比如60年代、朋克，以及我们在现代英国熟悉的所有这类事物，你认为，把类似的事情发生在摄政时期看作是时代的错置吗？
kind of metropolitan places so in other words if you think about a different era like you know the joke that's always made about the 1960s say is that everybody is wearing a mini skirt in carnaby street but in hull people aren't wearing miniskirts until 2012. How soon are people in Hull wearing the new fashions that are inspired by the sort of the Emma Hamiltons of this world? Basically as soon as information and income will allow them to. So if you've got the wherewithal and you're waiting eagerly for news from London about what the latest fashions are, and you go into your local shop and go, all right, I'm going to buy a muzzle and try and imitate this, you can do it kind of fairly quickly.
摄政时期是历史上第一次伟大的时尚革命，在此之前时尚从未如此彻底、如此迅速地改变过，而且可以说随后的所有事物基本上都只是当时发生的事情的稍微加速版。有趣的是，“当今的女孩”——我的意思是使用我引用的“当今的女孩”这个人物形象，既是两者的中心，又是某种……几乎是一个令人畏惧的人物形象——这是否意味着人们对无法无的性放纵和炫耀等存在一种恐惧？我的意思是这在60年代穿迷你裙之类的时候当然是真的，这是真的吗？我这样认为在1790年代也同样适用吗？它绝对适用。随着时尚在1790年代和1800年代开始改变，
There is a school of thought that says that when, because one of the reasons I also like the Regency period is Australia has a history, colonised white history at this point. But the settlers in England, in Australia, who had a six-month wait for goods from Britain, actually, that wasn't much longer than if you're in the Welsh Hills or maybe the Scottish Highlands. So it could be relatively fast. And, in fact, there's a wonderful quote from the Irish author, Maria Edgeworth, who says that, you know, with the post and the roads that we have now, it's almost like everyone can know what everyone's doing at the same time
其独特的特征之一是它使用了更轻的面料，剪裁展现了更多的身体线条。回到束腹撑和紧身胸衣的区别上来，紧身胸衣是束腹撑的轻量版，仅由面料制成。事实上，它在法语中是“小身躯”的意思。这里重大而显著的变化是，束腹撑把胸部挤压成一种圆形的形状，就像船头一样。而新的紧身胸衣则给我们带来了两个乳房。在纯技术层面上，当你有两个像橘子一样坐在前面需要用布料包裹的胸部时，你必须完全以不同的方式裁剪衣服。仅仅通过女性乳房的轮廓就能被看到，这是令人震惊的。如果你习惯了看到顶部那种光滑的三角形形状，上面只有一点微微隆起的面包，那么看到女性身段清晰的轮廓是非常具有对抗性的。
and it's like magical fairies, which, you know, in our day and age seems very slow. But she was impressed by how soon people could know what was happening and what was in fashion but dominic dominic compared this to the 60s um where the the sense of a kind of generational divide and and um is very strong and also the kind of the pleasure that the fashionable take in shocking um people with more old-fashioned takes on on what you should be wearing and i was really struck you quote you quote a magazine that that describes shocked old ladies and snorting old gentlemen bewailing modern tendencies the total lack of respect the boldness of behavior of the
不仅如此，长裙的后背开线更低，所以你可以看到肩胛骨和脖子。袖子变短了，所以你能看到更多手臂和长裙的圆柱形线条。它们确实在臀部和腿部显得有些贴身。相比之下，这几乎是裸露的。它的结构要少得多。面料更透明。你没有那种遮盖。而且你可以看出——你知道的——女性有两只胳膊两条腿，把它们组合在一起。这相当令人震惊。但同样地，这不是60年代。这仍然是一个在很大程度上受宗教道德、行为标准等支配的社会。所以我想，在你所穿的衣服中——我的意思是，在一个快速变化的时期，时尚在不断变化，时尚反映出……
girl of today and in particular the extreme indelicacy of her clothing i mean that could be describing i mean that could be describing the 60s, couldn't it? I mean, and really, really strike. So, again, is basically all the kind of revolutions of fashion, say the 60s, punk, everything, all the kind of stuff that we're familiar with in modern Britain. Do you think, is it anachronistic to think of something similar to that happening in the Regency? The Regency is the first great fashion revolution never had before has fashion changed so radically and so quickly and it's it kind of everything that comes afterwards is just basically a slightly quicker version of what happened then and it's interesting that the girl that i mean to use that i'm quoting the girl of today that that that that figure is at the center of both but as a sort of
往往由上层阶级产生并向各省辐射。这大概就是为什么简·奥斯汀的小说如此关注行为、人们做错事、人们犯下微小的错误而导致自己被抛入社会遗忘边缘的原因？而且想必服装对简·奥斯汀的世界来说绝对是关键。它绝对是，因为统治中产阶级的那些“恰到好处但又不过分”的细微差别同样适用于服装。而且有很多例子——我在书中给出了一些——人们基本上都在说：“好吧，你必须知道什么是时尚，因为你不能太落后于时代。”但太追赶时尚也是不得体的，因为你不能落后于时代，但太追赶时尚却显得不得体。
um as almost a figure to be feared is it that there's a sort of fear of unbridled sexual excess and display and so on I mean that's certainly true in the 60s with the mini skirt and whatnot is that true am I right in thinking that's pretty much true in the 1790s as well? It absolutely is. And as the fashion starts to change in the 1790s and into the 1800s, one of the particular characteristics of it is it's using lighter fabrics and the cut shows off more of the body. And to go back to the sort of the difference between stays and corsets, corsets were lighter versions of stays that were just made of fabric. In fact, it's French for kind of little body. And the major significant change here is that stays kind of squished the bosom into sort of, you know, one round shape like the prow of a ship. And the new corsets gave us two breasts. And on a purely technical level, you have to cut
你必须占据一个非常特殊而狭窄的地带：既要像其他人一样、不过于老派，但你又不想太激进。你不想走得太极端，因为那是不体面的。如何平衡这一点——中产阶级花了很多时间思考如何在他们的服装中表达这一点。是的，这确实是一个贯穿她所有小说的宏大主题。我想我们此时应该休息一下。当我们回来时，也许我们可以看看男女服装的具体细节，因为我认为你书中让人大开眼界的事情之一，其实是男装的革命——
things completely differently when you've got sort level, you have to cut things completely differently when you've got sort of, you know, two oranges sitting up the front there to be draped. And the visibility just through silhouette of the female breast was, it was shocking. If you're used to seeing kind of this smooth triangular shape up the top with, you know, a little bit of rising bread at the top of it, to see the clear outline of the female figure, it's very confronting. Not only that, you get lower back lines of gowns, so you see sort of shoulder blades and necks. The sleeves get shorter, so you're seeing more of the arm and the columnar shape of the gowns. They do kind of cling a bit over the hips and legs.
男装的革命也许是最持久的。从某种意义上说，我们至今仍生活在其中。汤姆，这就是我对长期以来一直思考并在之前和你讨论过的问题的答案：人们是什么时候开始穿长裤的？好吧，我们将回答这个问题。所以我们几分钟后见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论，
So by comparison, this is naked. This is it's far less structured. The fabric is more transparent. You don't have that covering. And you can kind of see that, you know, women have two arms and two legs and join them all together. It's quite a shock. But equally, this isn't the 60s. This is still a society
还有少许演艺界八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐界的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告音频、加更节目和抢先购买现场门票，请前往 restisentertainment.com，网址是 restisentertainment.com。最完美厕所的产物应该是一个优雅的女人，而不是一个穿着优雅的女人。这当然是达西先生的话。永恒的话语，永恒的准则。我们现在和希拉里·戴维森在一起，她在第一部分中带我们对摄政时期的时尚进行了一场
very much governed by kind of religious morality, standards of behavior and so on. And so I'm guessing that what you wear, I mean, in a period of rapid change where fashions are changing and where the fashions reflect, you know, tend to be generated by the upper classes and they ripple outwards into the provinces.
精彩绝伦的巡礼。希拉里，既然我们已经讨论了这是一个革命性的过程，即第一个伟大的时尚时代，我们能否具体看看女性服装在摄政时期的这30年——我们称之为摄政时期，即1790年代和19世纪的前二十年——里是如何变化的？变革进程中如此激进的到底是什么？嗯，正如我所说，你所装扮的身体的轮廓和概念发生了根本性的改变。每个时期都有其理想的身体。从结构化、正式、讲究礼仪的18世纪身体，我们突然对所谓的“自然身体”有了新的欣赏。并看到身体本来的形状。这是一个非常根本的变化，它随后支撑了服饰发生的如此多的改变。
This presumably is why jane austen's novels are so concerned with behavior people doing the wrong things people committing the tiny little mistake that gets them kind of cast out into social oblivion and presumably then dress is absolutely key to this to jane austen's world in that sense. It absolutely is because all of those nuances of enough but not too much that so rule the middle classes apply to clothing as well. And there's lots of examples, which I give a few in the book, of people saying basically, all right, you have to know what's in fashion because you can't be too behind the times. But it's not seemly to be too much in fashion because you can't be too behind the times, but it's kind of, it's not seemly to be too much in fashion.
从非常僵硬的束腹撑转变为更柔软的紧身胸衣，随后演变为19世纪由棉制成、骨条较少并反映身体形状的紧身胸衣，这正是源于身体观念的变化。这也随后改变了裁剪长裙的方式，因为如果你底下有不同的支撑结构，你就必须以不同的方式裁剪。最大的变化——也是最能定义摄政时期女性服装的变化——是腰线一直上升到胸部下方，并且在那里维持了大约20年之久。这也改变了你可以搭配的款式。
You have to occupy a quite particular narrow ground of, you know, being like everyone else, you know, not being too old fashioned, but you don't want to go too radical. You don't want to go too extreme because it's not respectable. And how to kind of balance that is it spends, the middle class has spent a lot of time thinking about how to express that in their clothing. Yeah. And that's such a theme, isn't it? All the way through all her novels. I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, perhaps we could look at the specifics of how female and male clothing, because I thought one of the most eye-opening things in your book was the way in which actually male clothing, the revolution in male clothing,
你不能在胸部下方拖着一条巨大的裙子，因为正如任何摄政时期宫廷礼服的照片所显示的，那看起来太荒谬了。所以它随后改变了你可以对剩余面料做的事情。转向短袖也改变了那里的装饰可能性，因为你有了新的服装结构可以发挥。而且正在发生的大部分工业革命都与纺织品有关。所以你有了新的面料，特别是在花边和针织领域。一旦有了新事物，人们就会想要尝试。因此，你拥有了所有这些新理念，比如透视和多层服装搭配，这些在摄政时期开始出现，但在以前除了通过丝绸纱布等有限的方式外，在物理上是不可能的。然后你有了新的头饰，比如女帽（bonnet）的出现。
is perhaps the most enduring. In a sense, we're still living with it now. This is the answer, Tom, to a question that I have long pondered, which I've discussed with you before. When did people start wearing trousers? Well, we will answer that question. So we will see you back in a few minutes. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
也许是最持久的。从某种意义上说，我们现在依然生活在它的影响之下。汤姆，这就是我长期以来一直思考的一个问题的答案，我以前也和你讨论过。人们是从什么时候开始穿裤子的？好吧，我们会解答这个问题的。那么我们几分钟后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐秘史》。这是你们每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论，
splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to rest is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com the result of the finest toilet should be an elegant woman not an elegantly dressed woman. That, of course, was Mr. Darcy. Timeless words, timeless ruling. And we are with Hilary Davidson, who is taking us in the first part through an
以及各种娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、获得独家番外以及提前购买现场门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com，即therestisentertainment.com。最完美厕所的产物应该是一个优雅的女人，而不是一个穿着优雅的女人。那句话当然出自达西先生之口。永恒的话语，永恒的准则。我们请来了希拉里·戴维森，她将在前半部分带我们进行一次
absolutely brilliant tour de raison of Regency fashion. And Hilary, now we've discussed how this is a kind of revolutionary process, the first great age of fashion. Could we look specifically at how women's clothing changes over the course of the 30 years of the, let's call it the Regency period, the 1790s and the first two decades of the 19th century? What is it exactly that is so radical about the process of change? Well, as I say, the silhouette and the concept of what the body that you're dressing on changes fundamentally. Every period has its kind of ideal body. And from the kind of structured, formal mannered 18th century body, we suddenly have a new appreciation of quote unquote, the natural body. And to see the body in the shape that it was. This is a really fundamental change that then underpins so much of the change that happens
绝对精彩的摄政时期时尚之旅。希拉里，我们刚才讨论了这是一种怎样的革命性过程，即时尚的第一个伟大时代。我们能否具体看看在摄政时期的这30年里——也就是我们所说的20世纪90年代到19世纪头二十年——女性服装是如何随时间变化的？这种变革过程最激进的地方究竟在哪里？嗯，正如我所说，轮廓以及你所要装扮的身体的概念发生了根本性的变化。每个时期都有其某种理想的身体形态。从那种结构化、正式且讲究礼仪的18世纪体态，我们突然对所谓的“自然身体”有了新的认识。并以其原本的形状来审视身体。这是一个非常根本的改变，它随后支撑了
with dress. The change from very stiff stays to the softer corsets that then will emerge into the 19th century corsets with kind of less boning made of cotton and reflecting the shape of the body. That is coming from the kind of the changes in the body. That also then changes how you cut a dress because you have to do it differently if you've got a different supporting structure underneath. The biggest change and the one that most defines Regency women's dress is that the waistline goes up to underneath the bust and it stays there for about 20 years. So that also changes the styles that you can put onto that.
服装发生的诸多变革。从非常硬挺的紧身胸衣，到后来在19世纪出现的更柔软的紧身胸衣，这些紧身胸衣含有的鱼骨较少，由棉布制成，并且呼应了身体的曲线。这是源于身体本身的变化。这也随之改变了服装的剪裁方式，因为如果你底下有不同的支撑结构，你就必须以不同的方式来进行剪裁。最大的变化，也是最能定义摄政时期女性着装特征的变化，是腰线上移到了胸部下方，并且在那里维持了大约20年之久。所以这也改变了你可以搭配的款式。
You can't kind of have a huge skirt coming out from underneath your bust because it looks ridiculous as any pictures of Regency court dress will show. So it then changes what you can do with the rest of the fabric. The move to short sleeves also changes the decorative possibilities there because you've got a new structure of clothing on which to play. And then a lot of the industrial revolution that's happening is to do with textiles. So you've got new fabrics, especially in the realm of lace and knitting. And once you have new things, people want to play with it. So you've got all of these kind of new ideas like transparency and multi-layering of clothing coming into Regency dress that just wasn't physically possible before, except in limited ways with things like silk gauze. And then you have new headwear like the bonnet coming in.
你不能让一条巨大的裙子从胸部下方直接垂下来，因为那样看起来会很荒谬，任何摄政时期的宫廷服饰图片都能证明这一点。因此，它改变了你可以对剩余面料做的事情。短袖的出现也改变了那里的装饰可能性，因为你有了新的服装结构可以发挥。而且，工业革命的许多进展都与纺织品有关。因此，你有了新的面料，尤其是在蕾丝和针织领域。一旦有了新鲜玩意儿，人们就想去尝试。所以，诸如透明感和服装多层叠穿等各种新创意开始进入摄政时期的服饰中，这在以前除了通过丝绸纱之类的东西有局限性地实现外，在物理上是不可能的。接着，诸如女帽之类的新头饰也开始出现。
Right, which is absolutely the marker of a Jane Austen, isn't it? So they're always going on about their bloody bonnets and jane austen books aren't they i mean they care about nothing more than their bonnets would you would you say that um the the saliency of bonnets in jane austen adaptations is reflective of the reality or is is it a period a kind of costume drama uh fantasy it's women wore some kind of headwear all the time. A bonnet was one of multiple options for that. And also what we think of now is that classic, you know, deep brimmed thing. For Regency dresses, a bonnet could also mean a soft cap like a scotch bonnet.
没错，这绝对是简·奥斯汀作品的标志，不是吗？所以他们总是喋喋不休地谈论他们那些该死的小帽和简·奥斯汀的书，不是吗？我的意思是，除了小帽，他们什么都不关心。你会不会说，呃，简·奥斯汀改编作品中小帽的显眼程度反映了现实呢，还是说这是一种时代特色、一种古装剧幻想呢？女性无时无刻不在戴着某种头饰。小帽只是其中的多种选择之一。而且，我们现在所认为的那个经典款，你知道的，带有深帽檐的东西。对于摄政时期的连衣裙来说，小帽也可以指一种像苏格兰无边帽那样的软帽。
So the kind of the brimmed item, it was one, convention, and two, it kept the sun off your face, which was important for their notions of beauty about not being tanned. One of the criticisms of Lizzie Bennet in Pride and Prejudice is that she's become brown with the sun. And obviously there's all sorts of implications in that as well. So headwear was important, but it wasn't necessarily always a bonnet. But you always have your hair long, presumably. Yes. Well, not actually. No. In this period, we have some interesting things. It's another radical thing that happens. Women can have their hair cropped and quite short, like a pixie cut. And there is-
所以那种带有帽檐的物件，第一，它是一种习俗；第二，它能挡住脸上的阳光，这对于他们关于不变黑的审美观念来说很重要。在《傲慢与偏见》中，对莉兹·班内特的一个批评就是她被太阳晒黑了。显然，这里面也有各种各样的含义。因此，头饰很重要，但不一定非得是小帽。不过，据推测，你们的头发总是留得很长。是的。嗯，其实也不是。不。在这个时期，我们有一些有趣的事情。这是发生的又一件激进的事情。女性可以把头发剪短，剪得相当短，就像精灵短发一样。并且有——
Paranightly, yeah. Exactly. Exactly. And it's thought that a lot of this does actually, this one comes from the French Revolution, where aristocrats who had had relatives who had been executed would actually go to parties à la victime, and they would crop their hair in imitation of those who had their hair cut off before they went to the guillotine. That's a bit weird. Yeah, that is quite.
帕拉奈特式的，对吧。完全正确。完全正确。而且人们认为，这其中很大一部分其实——这个来源可以追溯到法国大革命，当时那些有亲属被处决的贵族会去参加“仿效受害者”（à la victime）的派对，他们会模仿那些在被送上断头台之前被剃光头发的人，把自己的头发剪短。这有点诡异。对，确实挺诡异的。
But yeah, for the first time, women could actually have short hair, and it was sort of part of this radical newness men cut theirs off as well but in general it was long and if it was long it was never out never this kind of you know half up hair flowing romantical style that's beloved on screen just doesn't exist in the regency period it was always always up, basically. Always up. Right. And one of the, I mean, again, anyone who has particularly watched film TV adaptations of Jane Austen, I guess particularly Pride and Prejudice, where Lizzie Bennet is always walking, isn't she?
但对吧，女性在历史上第一次可以剪短头发，这有点像是这种激进的新潮事物的一部分，男人们也把头发剪短了。但总的来说，头发还是长的；如果头发是长的话，它也绝不会披散着，绝对不会是这种，你知道的，半扎半披、充满浪漫色彩的发型——这种在银幕上备受喜爱的发型在摄政时期根本不存在。它基本上总是、总是盘起来的。总是盘起来。没错。而且其中一个——我的意思是，同样地，任何看过简·奥斯汀影视改编作品的人，特别是《傲慢与偏见》吧，莉兹·班内特总是在走路，不是吗？
Presumably, it's more difficult for women to ride than it is for men. So in a sense, they're obliged to walk. And to what extent does that influence the direction of fashion for women? Well, one of the things I really want to explore in the book and to challenge was this idea of kind of women as sort of, you know, helpless, languorous beasts kind of stuck on their sofa. And, you know, one of the joys about that adaptation is that it really showed the physicality of daily life. And there's lots of records of the joys about that adaptation is that it really showed the physicality of daily life.
据推测，女性骑马比男性更困难。所以在某种程度上，她们不得不走路。这在多大程度上影响了女性时尚的方向？嗯，我在书中非常想探讨并挑战的一个观点就是，那种把女性视为某种无助、慵懒、困在沙发上的动物的看法。而且，你知道的，关于那部改编作品的一个乐趣就在于，它真正展现了日常生活的身体力行。而且有很多关于——关于那部改编作品的一个乐趣就在于，它真正展现了日常生活的身体力行。
And there's lots of records of Regency women doing 20-mile walks. And in a sense, the fact that shoes lose their heels for women, they become completely flat. This really encouraged especially middle-class women to be able to walk more. And there's lots of walking shoes with kind of studded soles that give you grip on muddy surfaces. But it's also kind of a matter of economics because a horse was expensive to maintain and it was often kind of a working thing. So, if there was a horse in the household, it's likely that the men would have to use it for their business. So, walking was very practical and it's also a way of reinforcing social interactions. You know. You walk to the village
并且有很多关于摄政时期的女性进行20英里徒步的记录。从某种意义上说，女性鞋子失去了鞋跟，变得完全平底，这一事实确实鼓励了特别是中产阶级女性能够走更多的路。而且有很多带有鞋底钉的步行鞋，能在泥泞的地面上提供抓地力。但这在某种程度上也是一个经济问题，因为养马成本很高，而且马通常用于劳作。因此，如果家里有一匹马，男人们很可能会为了他们的生意而不得不使用它。所以，走路非常实用，这也是加强社交互动的一种方式。你知道的。你步行去村里
and back, but you also have a whole lot of outer clothing that supports this walking, things like cloaks and palaces and patterns, which are a kind of a high raised clog that keep you out of, on unpaved roads, it's dusty in summer, it's muddy in winter. So there is lots of clothing that supports this physical activity as well in this period. And you say that of Jane Austen's actual dress, the only known survivals are a pelisse and a shawl and then various items of jewellery. That's right.
然后走回来，但你同时还拥有一整套支持这种步行的外衣，比如斗篷、长外衣（pelisses）和套鞋（patterns）——这是一种高底的木屐，能让你在没有铺砌的路上免受侵害，夏天防尘，冬天防泥。因此，在这个时期，也有大量的服装来支持这种体育活动。你提到在简·奥斯汀实际穿着的衣物中，现存仅知的只有一件长外衣、一条披肩以及各种首饰。没。
But would Jane Austen have worn high heels? No, they weren't in fashion. So people had worn heels 50 years, certainly 100 years earlier, but now they've gone out and they've gone out for women and for men? Yes. Except for Nicolas Sarkozy later in life. So we, on the podcast, we've been very anxious about the fact that the Kaiser, when he went to cows, yachting, wore the wrong shoes.
但简·奥斯汀会穿高跟鞋吗？不，那不流行。所以人们在50年前、甚至是100年前穿过鞋跟，但现在它们已经过时了，而且对女性和男性来说都过时了吗？是的。除了晚年的尼古拉·萨科齐。所以我们在播客中一直非常担心这样一个事实：德皇威廉二世去考斯（Cowes）玩帆船时，穿错了鞋子。
And essentially this was the cause of the First World War. Tom yachting, wore the wrong shoes. And essentially, this was the cause of the First World War. Tom, you also wore the wrong shoes on a yachting holiday. I did. You may be honest. I did. But I wondered, just on the topic of shoes, could you turn up at a ball at Pemberley and be wearing the wrong shoes? Would that bring shame on you? It would, absolutely. Unfortunately those it's one of those glitches of some historical productions that they've had male characters turn up to balls in boots no no oh dear i would have definitely worn boots to a ball well you'd have you'd have been flung out then wouldn't you shame on the name of sandbrook but i would have been in full military uniform people
从本质上讲，这就是第一次世界大战的起因。汤姆，你在帆船度假时也穿错了鞋子。我是穿了。你可以诚实点。我是穿了。但我想知道，就在鞋子这个话题上，你能穿着错的鞋子出现在彭伯利的舞会上吗？那会给你带来耻辱吗？绝对会。不幸的是，这也是一些历史影视作品的小瑕疵之一，它们让男性角色穿着靴子去参加舞会。不，不，噢天哪，我绝对会穿着靴子去参加舞会。好吧，那你肯定会被轰出去的，不是吗？森布鲁克家族的脸面都要丢尽了，但我会穿着全套军装，人们
would have welcomed me as a returning hero oh that, that's all right. If it's military uniform, that's fine. Yes. We will be coming to that in a minute. But just one last thing on what women are wearing. I said that by and large, men are likely to be riding horses than women, but you do say riding habits were Britain's most successful female dress export. So that's good to know. It is. Riding habits were basically the nearest imitation to men's dress that you could get in women's wardrobe. And it's a quite practical, usually a bodice and a skirt made out of wool, usually tailored like men's clothing and made by tailors who are making for men. And it was just kind of a hard wearing practical gown for riding but also for traveling and sort of sort of casual wear in a sense women are usually riding side saddle at this point so
会像迎接英雄归来一样欢迎我。噢，那，那没关系。如果是军装，那就没问题。是的。我们一会儿就会谈到这一点。但关于女性穿着，还有最后一点。我刚才说过，大体上男性比女性更可能骑马，但你也说过，骑马装是英国最成功的女性服装出口产品。所以这倒是个好消息。确实是。骑马装基本上是女性衣橱里所能找到的对男性服装的最接近的模仿。它相当实用，通常是一件毛呢紧身胸衣和裙子，通常像男装一样剪裁，由为男性制作服装的裁缝制作。它只是一种耐穿实用的长袍，适合骑马，也适合旅行，从某种意义上说，也是一种休闲装。由于此时女性通常侧坐骑马，所以
it also has quite voluminous skirts to hide the legs uh which shift slightly and so when when say um 1850 after the battle of waterloo british women go to Paris. Do they look completely odd to the French? I mean, do they look really, they say yes, you know, anglaise? It's quite interesting. You can trace a definite shift in British fashion from about 1814. Because, of course, in 1814, we've got the first peace. And there is a kind of tour of European leaders that comes to Britain. So, you know, the Emperor of Russia is there.
它也有相当宽大的裙摆来隐藏双腿，双腿会稍微换一下位置。所以，当比如说，1850年滑铁卢战役之后，英国女性去巴黎时。她们在法国人眼里看起来会非常古怪吗？我的意思是，她们看起来真的很——法国人会说“噢，看呐，英国风（anglaise）”吗？这挺有意思的。你可以从大约1814年开始追踪到英国时尚的明确转变。因为，当然，在1814年，我们迎来了第一次和平。有一群访问英国的欧洲领导人巡游。所以，你知道的，俄罗斯沙皇也在那里。
And his sister, the Grand Duchess of Oldenburg, who has a very influential bonnet, the very high-crowned Oldenburg bonnet sweeps Europe. And that's when you start to sort of get, I mean, there's been interaction between France and Britain for fashion during the whole Napoleonic War period. But that's when you start to get people going, oh, look at what the French are doing. And when the English go to Paris, the French think they look slightly dowdy and old-fashioned and they're too interested in historicalness.
还有他的妹妹、奥尔登堡大公夫人，她戴着一顶极具影响力的小帽——那个高皇冠的奥尔登堡小帽风靡了整个欧洲。也就是从那时起，你开始接触到——我的意思是，在整个拿破仑战争期间，法国和英国之间就时尚问题进行过互动。但也就是从那时起，你开始听到人们说，“噢，快看法国人在做什么”。当英国人去巴黎时，法国人会觉得他们看起来有点土气、过时，而且他们对历史感的关注度太高了。
I know, right? Who'd have thought? It's unbelievable. Unbelievable. Nobody ever says that about the English. I mean, that's shocking. And the French looked, they still had kind of higher waists, but their skirts were starting to get a bit broader.
我懂，对吧？谁能想到呢？这简直难以置信。难以置信。从来没有人这样评价过英国人。我的意思是，这太让人震惊了。而法国人看起来——他们仍然保留着较高的腰线，但他们的裙摆开始变得稍微宽大了一些。
And there's all these slight changes that happen in British fashion between about 1814, 15, where it kind of comes more into line with French fashion. And you start getting people sort of talking about the things they brought back from Paris, and also how customs is confiscating some of the things they brought back from Paris. And, you know, they're not very happy about that. So hold on, just to recap, Nikolaus von Heidloff, when he said the English were absolute top dogs in the sartorial arena, are you saying that this view was not, in fact, universally held?
在大约1814年到1815年之间，英国时尚发生了一系列微小的变化，使其更加符合法国时尚。你开始听到人们谈论他们从巴黎带回来的东西，以及海关是如何没收他们从巴黎带回来的部分物品的。（而且，你知道的，他们对此很不高兴。）等等，我们来回顾一下，当尼古拉·冯·海德洛夫（Nikolaus von Heidloff）说英国人在时尚界绝对是老大时，你是说这种观点其实并没有得到普遍认同吗？
That some people thought the English were a bit boring and fusty and reactionary in their dress? Is that right? Well, they did, but it was the French who thought that. So is that, yeah. Yeah yeah they would wouldn't they but also hillary i mean i mean isn't it isn't it the case that that perhaps female fashion is seen as being less cutting edge less less kind of must have very much on the continent but male fashion is i gather from your book absolutely the bee's knees anglomania it is anglomania and you know it's remarkable how appropriate it becomes there's there's quotes saying that you
有些人认为英国人在着装上有点无聊、守旧和保守？是这样吗？嗯，确实有人这么认为，但那是法国人这么认为的。所以是这样，对吧。对，对，他们当然会这么认为。但是，希拉里，我的意思是——难道女性时尚在欧洲大陆不一直被认为是不那么前沿、不那么必备的吗？而男装，根据我对你书的理解，绝对是最棒的——“迷英狂热”（Anglomania）。确实是“迷英狂热”，你知道的，它变得如此契合，这真是非同寻常。有引语说
know if you are if you are dressed in the english style you are well dressed anywhere on the continent for me i mean that is that hasn't changed has it that's very true today um so so what what so what is it about well two questions first of all what changes about male dress in britain over the 1790s and the first two decades of the 19th century and what is it about those changes that that strikes people on the continent as as so appealing this is kind of a it's a it's a twofold answer because like much of the changes, this has also been building during the 1770s and 80s. And what distinguishes English men's dress from the French is, in a sense, it's casualness, it's comfort. The notion of the English country gentleman who is in good solid leather breeches, he's wearing riding boots,
如果你穿着英国风格的衣服，你在欧洲大陆的任何地方都能穿得体面。对我来说，我的意思是，这并没有改变，对吧？今天依然如此，嗯。那么——那么——那么到底是什么——有两个问题，首先，在1790年代和19世纪的前二十年里，英国男装发生了什么变化？以及这些变化中究竟是什么让欧洲大陆的人们觉得如此吸引人？这是一个——这是一个双重的答案，因为就像许多变化一样，这也是在1770年代和80年代逐渐积累起来的。英国男装区别于法国男装的特点在于，从某种意义上说，是它的随性、它的舒适。英国乡村绅士的理念是：他穿着结实厚实的皮马裤，穿着骑马靴，
and he's got a well-tailored but plain coat that sort of suits him, that he can jump on a horse, he can stride around with the hounds in. It's kind of emblematic of more ease and freedom, but also his kind of more democratic abilities as kind of master of it. He doesn't have to wear the kind of court Versailles. The peruke and the buckles. Yeah, and all of the embroidery and the silk.
穿着一件剪裁合体但朴素、适合他自己的外套，可以随时跳上马背，跟猎犬一起四处奔跑。这象征着更多的轻松和自由，同时也象征着他作为主人的那种更具民主风范的能力。他不必穿凡尔赛宫那种风格的衣服。假发和扣饰。对，还有所有的刺绣和丝绸。
So it's quite a distinct figure from that. So sort of the country squire has always been held up like that, and Anglomania really starts to kind of take off in probably the 1780s. So as these kind of new changes come in, it's seen that this style that is there in England, it becomes even more embraced. And within England, there's an increasing kind of, I suppose, trickle up. You get a lot of men being made fun of for dressing like they're
所以这是一个与那种风格截然不同的形象。因此，乡村乡绅的形象一直受到这样的推崇，“迷英狂热”大约在1780年代真正开始兴起。因此，随着这些新变化的引入，人们认为英国存在的这种风格得到了更广泛的接受。在英国国内，出现了一种日益明显的——我想可以说是“向上渗漏”的现象。很多男性因为穿着得像马夫、
grooms or dressing like jockeys, like working men who have kind of practical, comfortable clothing. So it's like Prince Harry or somebody wearing a baseball cap. Yes, exactly. Exactly. But there's a sort of emphasis on sobriety. Is that fair? So you're not dressing in a flamboyant way. You're not trying to look like a sort of fop. You're trying to look serious and you wear dark colours.
或者像骑师、像那些穿着实用舒适服装的劳动阶层而遭到嘲笑。这就像哈里王子或者什么人戴着棒球帽一样。对，没错。完全正确。但这里有一种对朴素的强调。这样说对吗？所以你不是穿得很浮夸。你不是在极力让自己看起来像个花花公子。你是在努力让自己看起来严肃，并且你穿深色衣服。
And that's new, right? Because previously men had dressed in very, very bold, dramatic, sort of bright colours. And in a way, I suppose you could say, this is one of those elements of this revolution that has endured. I mean, men do, by and large, dress much less brightly than women, don't they? They absolutely do.
这是全新的，对吧？因为在此之前，男装非常非常大胆、戏剧化、色彩鲜艳。从某种程度上说，我想你可以说，这是这场持续至今的革命的元素之一。我的意思是，男性的着装大体上确实比女性素净得多，不是吗？确实如此。
And what we also get from this period, and again, this is still where the English reputation maintains, is good tailoring. Yes, Savile Row. Yeah, Savile Row. Savile Row's greatness begins during this period because previously, the kind of the quality of the fabric and the embroidery and to a sense, the decoration was more important. But suddenly, you start to get more of an emphasis on kind of quite subdued or austere fabric, but cut beautifully. So it makes you look better and it enhances the body and it enhances the shoulder.
我们从这个时期获得的另一个特点——而且这也是英国声誉得以维持的地方——就是精湛的裁缝手艺。是的，萨维尔街。对，萨维尔街。萨维尔街的辉煌正是始于这一时期，因为在此之前，面料的质量、刺绣以及某种程度上的装饰更为重要。但突然之间，你开始更加强调相当低调或朴素的面料，但剪裁极其精美。因此它能让你看起来更好，衬托你的身形，并突显你的肩膀。
And you get this new kind of emphasis on this kind of still what is the template male figure of like broad shoulders, strong neck, narrow waist, strong hips, which is also coming from classical statues and the classical ideal. So it's all working in together. But the sense of that the quality of the fabric is not immediately visible, but it's how it's tailored and shaped that's important springs from this period. Well, Hilary, I have a bespoke suit from Sao Paulo. And it does make me look like a Greek god. It's amazing.
并且你获得了对这种——仍然是男性模板身形的全新强调：宽阔的肩膀、强健的脖子、纤细的腰身、强壮的臀部，这也源自古典雕像和古典理想。所以这一切都在协同发挥作用。但是，面料本身的质量不是一眼就能看出来的，而是它的剪裁和版型——这一点至关重要——正是源于这一时期。好吧，希拉里，我有一套来自萨维尔街的定制西装。它确实让我看起来像个希腊神祇。太神奇了。
Which one? Hephaestus.'s amazing Hephaestus yeah Hephaestus exactly the band a friend of mine who was fabulously rich said I think I can get you a special deal with my tailor I was so excited about it
哪一个？赫菲斯托斯的。惊人的赫菲斯托斯，对，赫菲斯托斯，没错，乐队。我一个非常有钱的朋友说，我觉得我可以帮你从我的裁缝那里弄到一个特惠价，我当时激动坏了
and he did get me a special deal but it was still so expensive it was eye-wateringly expensive I'm sure Tom that will I'm sure, Tom, that will, I'm sure the listeners will love hearing this detail. It makes you really relatable. Well, I might post a photo of myself in my Savile Racing. Oh, that will really endear you to the public.
他确实帮我搞到了一个特别优惠，但它依然太贵了，贵得让人瞠目结舌。我确信，汤姆，这会让——我确信，汤姆，这会——我确信听众们会很喜欢听到这个细节。这让你显得非常平易近人。好吧，我可能会发一张我穿着萨维尔街赛车服的照片。哦，那可真会赢得公众的喜爱呢。
Yeah, do. But still, you, I mean, say, you know, if you're really a Regency gentleman, you'd actually be going to different tailors for your coat and for your waistcoat and your trousers and obviously obviously the role model for a well-dressed man about town like myself as as he has always been is beau brummel who yes cuts a tremendous dash in your book um so if people who don't know about beau brell, who is basically the model of fine English tailoring and dressing, isn't he? Just tell us about him and how cool he is.
对，发吧。不过话说回来，如果你真的是一个摄政时期的绅士，你实际上会为你的外套、你的马甲和你的裤子去不同的裁缝店。而且，显然，对于像我这样注重穿着的时尚男士来说，楷模一直都是博·布鲁梅尔（Beau Brummell），他在你的书中确实大放异彩。那么，如果有人不了解博·布鲁梅尔——他基本上是精美英国裁缝和着装的典范，不是吗？给我们讲讲他以及他有多酷。
So Beau Brummell is very interesting because he was not aristocratic. This is a key point about him. He was a middle class fellow. I mean, he still went to Eton, but he was in... So he's not Alexander McQueen. But that kind of thing, in Regency terms. So he's not Alexander McQueen. But that kind of thing in Regency terms. Yeah, exactly. And he was just incredibly well-dressed and attentive to clothing himself,
所以博·布鲁梅尔非常有趣，因为他并非贵族出身。这是关于他的一个关键点。他是个中产阶级小伙。我的意思是，他还是去了伊顿公学，但他在……所以他不是亚历山大·麦昆。但在摄政时期的语境下，就是那种感觉。所以他不是亚历山大·麦昆。但在摄政时期的语境下，就是那种感觉。对，完全正确。他只是对穿着打扮极其讲究且细心，
but not in a showy way, in a subdued way. So he was about having the best of things, but not being ostentatious. Beautifully laundered shirts, beautifully cut jackets, you know, perfect trousers. But his ideal was always that the man in the street should not turn and look at you. You should be so perfectly dressed, you are invisible. And his ideas and way of dressing was kind of like a breath of fresh air. But I mean, I should also say it's very much encapsulating what is already happening in clothing. And he's like the best, he's the apotheosis of what this is. And he ended up becoming friends with the Prince Regent
但不是以炫耀的方式，而是以低调的方式。所以他追求的是拥有最好的东西，而不是显摆。浆洗得精美的衬衫，剪裁完美的夹克，你知道的，完美的裤子。但他的理想永远是：街上的行人不应该回头看你。你应该穿得如此完美，以至于你隐形了。他的理念和着装方式就像是一股清风。但我的意思是，我也应该指出，这在很大程度上概括了服装界已经发生的变化。他就像是这一切的最佳代表，是这一切的顶峰。他最终与摄政王成为了朋友，
and kind of really influencing his clothing and had much more powerful reach about ideas about dress that weren't necessarily about showiness. They were about quality and understanding and connoisseurship in clothing that have become incredibly influential. And as I say, he's the figure who best started doing that and wasn't an aristocrat.
并在很大程度上影响了摄政王的着装，他对不一定关乎炫耀的着装理念产生了更强大的影响力。它们关乎服装的品质、理解力和鉴赏力，并变得极具影响力。正如我所说，他是最先开始这样做且并非贵族出身的人物。
And so he looms large over dress history. Well, perhaps through Beau Brummel, we can come to the absolutely key question, which is about trousers. So Beau Brummel wears trousers. You have always wondered about this. Well, I said to you in an earlier podcast ages ago. I know, I remember.
因此，他在服饰史上有着举足轻重的地位。好吧，也许通过博·布鲁梅尔，我们可以切入那个绝对核心的问题，也就是关于裤子的事。所以博·布鲁梅尔穿裤子。你一直对此感到好奇。嗯，我很久以前在之前的播客里对你说过。我知道，我记得。
That years and years ago, Tom, when I was doing my PhD, I went for a drink with Ted Vallance, who's been on our podcast to talk about Magna Carta and about the execution of Charles I. And I said to him, Ted, when did people start wearing trousers? And despite the fact that he was doing a PhD at the same time on early modern history, he couldn't give me a definitive date. Because it's not his period, as he would have known it had he read Hilary's book.
那是好多年以前，汤姆，当我在读博士时，我和泰德·瓦伦斯（Ted Vallance）去喝了杯酒。他曾上过我们的播客，谈论《大宪章》和查理一世的处刑。我对他说：“泰德，人们是从什么时候开始穿裤子的？”尽管他当时也在攻读早期现代史的博士学位，但他却无法给我一个确切的日期。因为这不是他的研究时期，正如他如果读过希拉里的书就会知道的那样。
Clearly, clearly. Tell us about trousers. Yeah, if I'm a man about town in 1770, I'm not wearing trousers. In 1820, I am wearing trousers. So when's that tipping point? It, again, begins to pick up speed in the 1790s for a couple of reasons. So when we talk about breeches, they are always knee length. They finish just underneath the knee.
显然，显而易见。给我们讲讲裤子吧。对，如果我是1770年代的一位时尚男士，我不穿裤子。而在1820年，我穿着裤子。那么那个转折点是什么时候？它同样在1790年代开始加速，原因有几个。所以当我们谈论马裤（breeches）时，它们总是及膝的。它们的裤脚刚好在膝盖下方结束。
And the only, this is sort of standard, you know, middle class and upper wear and working wear as well. And the only people who are wearing lower garments, the only men who are wearing lower garments that run from the waist all the way down to the ankle are sailors. And they're wearing kind of loose, comfortable trousers on board ship, some working men as well. And this in a sense is also what they mean by the sans culotte in the French Revolution. They mean they're not wearing breeches, they're wearing trousers. So in another one of these trickle up moments we get a new popularity for ankle reaching legwear in the 1790s thanks to war because men in the army are wearing pantaloons which are kind of
唯一的——这可以说是标准的，你知道的，中产阶级、上层阶级以及劳动阶层的穿着。而唯一穿着下半身服装的人——唯一穿着从腰部一直延伸到脚踝的下装的男性是水手。他们在船上穿着宽松舒适的裤子，一些劳工也是如此。从某种意义上说，这也是他们在法国大革命中所说的“无套裤汉”（sans-culotte）的意思。他们的意思不是穿着马裤，而是穿着长裤。所以在又一个这种“向上渗漏”的时刻，由于战争，我们在1790年代迎来了到达脚踝的裤装的新流行，因为军队里的士兵穿着紧身裤（pantaloons），它们有点像
in between breeches and trousers that they're completely tight fitting to the leg but they run all the way down so they're tight like breeches, but they're long like trousers. Hold on. I'm just trying to get my head around pantaloon. A pantaloon is like a legging. Yeah. So what's Nelson wear? Does he wear trousers or pantaloons? He's wearing, for full dress, he's wearing breeches. And then I think if he's just hanging around the cabin,
马裤和长裤之间，它们完全紧贴腿部，但一直延伸到底部——所以它们像马裤一样紧身，但像长裤一样长。等等。我正在努力理解紧身裤（pantaloons）的概念。紧身裤就像是打底裤。对。那么纳尔逊穿什么？他穿长裤还是紧身裤？他在穿正装时，穿的是马裤。然后我想，如果他只是在船舱里闲晃，
he's wearing white dog trousers with the lads. So military men and naval men are wearing these ankle-length garments. And as the Napoleonic Wars increase and the respect and admiration of the nation increases for these men as well, trousers start to become fashionable. So, again, it's a kind of a casualization because, first of all, pantaloons are easier to get into boots, which you're wearing for riding. So as riding boots become more popular, pantaloons work with them. And they start to creep into fashion. So I think it's in 18, oh, gosh, early on, the Duke of Wellington was actually refused admission to Ulmax,
他就和伙计们一起穿着白色粗斜纹布长裤。所以军人和海军人员都在穿着这些及踝的服装。随着拿破仑战争的加剧，国家对这些男人的尊重和钦佩也与日俱增，长裤开始变得流行起来。所以，这也是一种休闲化，因为首先，紧身裤更容易塞进骑马时穿的靴子里。随着骑马靴越来越受欢迎，紧身裤与它们很搭。它们开始悄悄进入时尚界。所以我想那是在18，噢，天哪，早期的时候，威灵顿公国实际被拒绝进入奥尔马克（Almack's）——
the most exclusive social club, because he was wearing trousers. I think it's about sort of the 1810s. He wore the wrong trousers. He wore the wrong trousers. Wow, history could have been changed there as well. Yeah. Didn't matter how famous you were, it was still not considered acceptable. But by about 1820, the use of these trousers, whether tight like pantaloons or just sort of long as trousers that we have now, had just become normalised. Right.
那个最高档的社交俱乐部，因为他穿着长裤。我想那大约是1810年代。他穿错了裤子。他穿错了裤子。哇，历史在那里也有可能被改变呢。对。不管你有多出名，这仍然被认为是不被接受的。但到了1820年左右，这些长裤的使用——无论是像紧身裤那样紧身，还是像我们现在这样宽松的长裤——都已经正常化了。没错。
And this is further compounded by the appearance of Russian Cossacks in London in 1814 who were wearing trousers that are pleated at the top and are quite full. And imitations of these became popular and were called Cossacks. Right. So I think Lord Liverpool, I think, was the first prime minister to have ever worn trousers. Because I think there's a famous portrait of Lord Liverpool where he's clearly wearing trousers. So that's my contribution to the old trousers.
1814年，俄罗斯哥萨克人来到伦敦，他们穿着在顶部有褶裥且相当肥大的裤子，这进一步加剧了这一趋势。对这些裤子的模仿开始流行起来，被称为“哥萨克裤”。没错。所以我想利物浦勋爵，我觉得是第一位穿过长裤的首相。因为我觉得有一幅著名的利物浦勋爵画像，里面他显然穿着长裤。所以这就是我对古老裤子话题的贡献。
Well, my contribution is that the most fashionable, the kind of, maybe the person who makes them really fashionable is Byron, because he has a club foot. And so wearing trousers enables him to disguise his club foot which I learned from your book yeah he's um he's he definitely finds them more comfortable and also he you know spends a lot of time in hotter areas they're sort of they're looser they're easier but Byron loved trousers because the length meant that he could hide his his little foot how much he actually popularised them may be sort of, you know, self-mythologising because he's not averse to that.
好吧，我的贡献是，最时髦的、那种——也许让裤子真正流行起来的人是拜伦，因为他有内翻足（club foot）。因此，穿长裤使他能够掩饰他的内翻足——我是从你的书中了解到的。对，他——他确实发现长裤穿起来更舒服，而且他也（你知道的）花很多时间在更炎热的地区，它们更宽松、更轻松。但拜伦喜欢长裤，因为长裤的长度意味着他可以藏起他的小脚。他实际上在多大程度上推广了长裤，可能有点（你知道的）自我神话化，因为他不排斥这样做。
But the, I mean, you touched on this, the idea that men in red coats and you, I mean, the Navy as well, you have a picture of a guy called Captain Gilbert Heathcote who, I mean, sensational. He's gorgeous. Yeah, I mean, he's... Yeah, you love this bloke, Tom, don't you? Well, I don't normally feel homoerotic slurrings, but... But you do.
但是，我的意思是——你刚才提到了这一点——身穿红色军服的男性，而且——我的意思是海军也是如此——你书中有一张一个叫吉尔伯特·希思科特（Gilbert Heathcote）船长的家伙的照片，我的意思是，太轰动了。他帅极了。对，我的意思是，他是……对，你很喜欢这家伙，汤姆，不是吗？好吧，我平时不会产生同性恋式的冲动，但是……但你确实有。
He's quite something. He's splendid. He's splendid. So basically, you say that looking at soldiers is a rare example of Regency women frankly appraising the physique of the opposite sex. And of course, as Mrs. Bennett, isn't that who famously says that there was a time when she liked a red coat. So we've talked about how, you know, with Beau Brummel and everything, men's tailoring is becoming sober and respectable. But presumably having all these kind of guys in bright red coats.
他相当了不起。他太帅了。太帅了。所以基本上，你提到注视士兵是摄政时期女性公然评价异性体格的一个罕见例子。当然，正如班内特太太——难道不是她 famously 说过曾经有一段时间她很喜欢红制服吗？所以我们已经讨论了，随着博·布鲁梅尔等人的出现，男装是如何变得严肃和体面的。但presumably，让所有这些穿着鲜红制服的家伙们——
With very tight trousers on. Well, yes. Okay. So this was my favorite sentence in your entire book. Anxieties about male evening dress involved tightness. So red coats and tightness. Talk us through that. Well, as women's waistline rose on dresses, the fronts of men's waistcoats were also rising.
穿着非常紧身的裤子。好吧，是的。好的。所以这是你整本书中我最喜欢的一句句子：关于男性晚礼服的焦虑涉及紧身。所以红军服和紧身。给我们讲讲这个吧。好吧，随着女性在连衣裙上的腰线上升，男性马甲的前襟也在上升。
So where in the 1770s or 80s they largely covered the groin, by the sort of about 1800, you suddenly had the entire area from the waist right down to the ankle visible. And so in men's dress, you also have coats that are cut away at the origin of our modern tailcoats with a slightly higher front and nothing to cover at the front. So there's a lot more of the male loins, shall we say, on display and in focus than there has previously been. And when you combine that with the appeal of the uniform on top, whether that's red for the army or kind of blue for the Navy, there's a lot to look at. Right. Okay. So would it be fair to say that, I mean, just elaborate what we touched on at the
因此，如果在1770年代或80年代，它们大体上盖住了腹股沟，那么到了1800年前后，你突然会看到从腰部一直到脚踝的整个区域都暴露无遗。所以在男装中，你也会看到在外衣起源处被剪短的外套，这成了现代燕尾服的雏形，前襟稍微高一些，前面没有任何遮挡。因此，与以往相比，男性的下半身（我们可以这么说）更多地展现在人们的视线中并成为焦点。当你把这一点与顶部的制服（无论是陆军的红色还是海军的蓝色）的吸引力结合起来时，确实有很多值得看的地方。好吧。那么这样说是否公平——我的意思是，详细阐述一下我们在这一段开头提到的内容——男装发生的变化中，有一种延续性一直保留到了今天？所以无论是人们穿非常紧身的牛仔裤，还是西装已经演变成一种全球统一的制服，这些潮流的源头都是这一时期的英国。
start of this section, that what happens with male dress, there is a continuity from this period that is still with us to this day. So whether it's people wearing, men wearing very tight jeans, whether it's a suit that has become a kind of global uniform, the origin point for those kind of trends are this period in Britain. Absolutely. And the way that men's dress transforms in the 1790s and 1800s sets the template for essentially Western men's dress that is still with us today. But can I ask about two things that's not with us today? One of them is wigs. So at what point do people drop wigs? Well, one of the interesting things I came across in my research is that it actually takes a while for people to drop wigs. They're just not so obvious. So the kind of the white powdered wig that is so emblematic of the 18th century, people still wear wigs.
绝对是。1790年代和1800年代男装的转变方式，为基本上延续至今的西方男装设定了模板。但我想问两件今天已经不存在的东西？其中之一就是假发。那么人们是在什么时候抛弃假发的呢？嗯，我在研究中发现的一个有趣现象是，人们花了一段时间才真正抛弃假发。它们只是不再那么显眼了。因此，那种作为18世纪标志的白色扑粉假发，人们仍然在戴假发。
They just do it with natural coloured hair. So, you know, you're wearing a wig, but it's, you know. It's a toupee. Brown. It could be your hair. It could be your hair. And so that's kind of it encompasses that change from artificial hair to natural hair. But we've got a really good example of when it starts to become a bit passé,
他们只是改用自然颜色的头发了。所以，你知道的，你戴着假发，但它是——这是一个男士假发片（toupee）。棕色。也可能是你自己的头发。也可能是你自己的头发。所以它包容了从人工假发向天然头发的这种转变。但我们有一个非常好的例子，说明它是什么时候开始变得有点过时的，
which is, unsurprisingly, the Prince Regent. By the time he becomes George IV, he's wearing a flaxen wig that is obviously just inappropriate for him, and it's commented upon because it looks so awkward and, you know, obviously bad. So he's wearing the wrong hair. Yeah. It's commented on by Bo Brummel, isn't it?
不出所料，那就是摄政王。当他成为乔治四世时，他戴着一顶亚麻色的假发，这对他来说显然很不合适，并且遭到了议论，因为它看起来那么别扭，而且（你知道的）显然很糟糕.所以他戴错了头发。对。博·布鲁梅尔对此进行了评论，不是吗？
Who's your fat friend? Because they have a kind of falling out. They do. Yeah. So allied to wigs, I mean, you couldn't wear a wig and this thing, are hats. So am I, forgive my ignorance, but basically do hats replace wigs? Because you can't wear both, can you? Oh, absolutely.
“谁是你那个胖朋友？”因为他们闹翻了。确实如此。对。与假发相关的——我的意思是，你不可能既戴假发又戴这个东西——就是帽子。所以我是不是——请原谅我的无知——基本上是帽子取代了假发？因为你不可能两者都戴，对吧？哦，绝对可以。
Yes, you can wear both. You can wear both. You can wear a tricorn hat. Yeah. I suppose you can, can't you? Yeah, of course you can't wear both can you oh absolutely yes you you can wear both you can wear a tricorn hat yeah i suppose you can can't you yeah of course you can stupid question so but people are still wearing hats that is to have the hats change as well because people obviously stop wearing tricorn hats they do and again you know so many things change in this period so we get top hats which we're you know we're so used to now. But you're absolutely right in identifying the tricorn hat. That's the kind of the typical hat of the 18th century, which is, you know, you take a round hat and you turn the brim up in three points, or you get the bicorn where you turn it up front and back,
是的，你可以两者都戴。你可以两者都戴。你可以戴一顶三角帽。对。我想你可以，不是吗？对，当然可以。你不可能两者都戴，对吧？哦，绝对可以。是的，你可以两者都戴。你可以戴一顶三角帽。对。我想你可以，不是吗？对，当然可以，真是个愚蠢的问题。所以，但人们仍然在戴帽子，帽子也变了吗？因为人们显然不戴三角帽了。他们确实不戴了。而且，你知道的，这个时期有很多事情都在改变。所以我们有了高顶礼帽（top hats），我们（你知道的）现在对它们太熟悉了。但你认出三角帽是完全正确的。那是18世纪的典型帽子，你知道的，你拿一顶圆帽，把帽檐在三个地方翻起来，或者你弄成双角帽（bricorn），把前后翻起来，
which is the very naval style. But we have these kind of higher crowned beaver hats, you know, made of beaver fur in the 1790s that have sort of a slightly angled in crown. And those crowns start to get straighter. So, this kind of stovepipe-y looking prototype of the top hat, it becomes more and more popular during all of this period that we're talking about until by 1820, which is when all of these changes seem to have kind of coalesced. We stopped getting the period of transition and people are like, okay, this is what clothing is now. Yep, yep.
这非常具有海军风格。但我们在1790年代拥有这种高皇冠的河狸皮帽（beaver hats，由河狸毛制成），它们的皇冠略微有些角度。而这些皇冠开始变得笔直。因此，这种类似烟囱管的高顶礼帽原型，在我们所谈论的整个时期里变得越来越受欢迎，直到1820年——此时所有这些变化似乎都已经融合在一起了。我们不再处于过渡时期，人们会觉得：“好吧，现在的服装就是这个样子的。”对，对。
Okay, good. Let's go. The top hat has become normal men's headwear. Right. That has completely replaced the tricorn. That looks archaic and rustic by this point. Tom, let me ask you this question. Would you prefer to have worn a top hat and trousers, very tight trousers,
好吧，很好。我们继续。高顶礼帽已经成为正常的男士头饰。没错。它完全取代了三角帽。到这个时候，三角帽看起来已经很古老和乡土气了。汤姆，让我问你这个问题：你更愿意戴高顶礼帽和紧身裤——非常紧身的裤子，
or would you prefer to have worn a tricorn hat and breeches and stockings? I would definitely, I would go for Beau Brummel. Would you? Yeah. I think everyone who knows me would say that I'm clearly a disciple of Beau Brummel. I would love to have worn a tricorn hat.
还是更愿意戴三角帽、马裤和长袜？我绝对——我会选博·布鲁梅尔。是吗？对。我想了解我的人都会说我显然是博·布鲁梅尔的信徒。我很想戴一顶三角帽。
Well, you'd look splendid. You would look like a kind of country squire, wouldn't you? Yeah, or a sort of corrupt excise man yes yeah absolutely like a sort of a cruel and rapacious excise man on the coast yes dealing with smugglers on a daily basis you need to have a slightly redder nose i think you drink a lot who's that bloke that i was likened to on the podcast squire all worthy is it squire all worthy or were you Squire Allworthy Squire Weston Squire Weston in Tom Jones yeah
好吧，你会看起来帅呆了。你会看起来像个乡村乡绅，不是吗？对，或者某种腐败的税吏。是的，对，绝对就像海岸上某个残酷贪婪的税吏，每天都要跟走私犯打交道。我觉得你需要一个稍微红一点的鼻子，你喝了很多酒。我在播客里被比作哪个家伙来着？“奥尔沃西绅士”（Squire Allworthy），是奥尔沃西绅士吗？还是你是奥尔沃西绅士？韦斯顿绅士（Squire Weston），在《汤姆·琼斯》里。对。
but I mean I like to think of myself as Mr Darcy so that's the difference between us so well I think you should
但我的意思是，我愿意把自己想象成达西先生，所以这就是我们之间的区别。所以，好吧，我觉得你应该——
I think when you know we should reenact these scenes shouldn't we we should I mean I'd pay good money
我觉得当——你知道的，我们应该重现这些场景，不是吗？我们应该。我的意思是，我愿意花大价钱
to see you coming out of a lake when the freezing cold I really love Regency Male Fashions it's actually one of the reasons why i want to do this podcast why i read henry's book um they are very elegant they really
看你从结冰的寒湖里走出来。我真的很喜欢摄政时期的男士时尚。这实际上也是我想做这个播客、想读希拉里的书的原因之一。它们非常优雅，真的
are and they they make me look great and hillary you're very much you're very much team 1815 not team 1780 am i right i mean i am i am i really i start to get interested in the 1790s lots of people love 18th century fashion i do lots of work on it, but it kind of, it leaves me cold until the 1790s. And then I'm just like, oh, look at all this stuff that's happening. Hilary, I am with Lady Elizabeth Whitbread, who you quote, who comes across a man dressed in the kind of things that Dominic would have been wearing. Are you not ashamed of yourself? You a man and an Englishman?
非常优雅，让我看起来棒极了。希拉里，你绝对是1815年战队，而不是1780年战队，我没说错吧？我的意思是，我是，我是。我真的——我从1790年代开始感兴趣。很多人喜欢18世纪的时尚，我也做过很多这方面的研究，但它——它让我提不起兴趣，直到1790年代。然后我就会觉得：“天哪，看看所有这些正在发生的事情。”希拉里，我和伊丽莎白·惠特布雷德（Lady Elizabeth Whitbread）女爵士站在同一阵线——你引用过她的话，她偶遇了一个穿着多米尼克可能会穿的那种衣服的男人。你不为你自己感到羞耻吗？你堂堂一个男人，还是个英国人？
Because he's wearing, he's wearing the wrong the wrong clothes too too fancy too too yeah colors are too bright uh and all that kind of stuff anyway um hillary thanks so much that was that was such fun and your book is so good uh so dress in the age of jane austen um all about regency fashion and it's not just brilliantly written but it has amazing illustrations as well it's a beautiful beautiful book. So if you have any interest in this subject, rush out and buy it. Thanks very much for listening and impeccably dressed as ever. We will be back for more podcasts very soon. Thank you very much. Thank you. Bye bye. Bye bye. thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening
因为他穿着——他穿错了衣服，太花哨了，太——对，颜色太鲜艳了，诸如此类的事情。无论如何，希拉里，非常感谢，这太有趣了。你的书太棒了。——《简·奥斯汀时代的着装》，全关于摄政时期的时尚。不仅文笔绝佳，而且还有精美的插图，这是一本非常美丽的精美书籍。所以，如果你对这个主题有任何兴趣，赶紧去买一本吧。非常感谢大家的收听，一如既往地衣着考究。我们很快就会回归更多精彩的播客。非常感谢。非常感谢。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History），想要获取独家单集、提前收听、无广告收听
and access to our chat community please sign up at rest is history pod.com that's rest isistorypod.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及访问我们的聊天社群，请在 restisistorypod.com 注册，网址是 restisistorypod.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。